lui est une étoile montante de la
République en marche le député des
hautes scènes Gabriel hatal devient
secrétaire d'État auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
à seulement 29 ans celui qui est aussi
conseiller municipal à vanve et le
benjamin de ce nouveau gouvernement le
plus jeune secrétaire d'État jamais
nommé il sera chargé notamment de mettre
en place le futur service national
universel en l'écoute l'engagement est
pour moi une valeur fondamentale du
projet d'Emmanuel Macron avec
l'émancipation l'engagement devrait être
dans notre devise républicaine
l'engagement c'est ce qui permet à tous
les Français de contribuer à l'intérêt
général on a de formidables outils
existants pour cela je pense notamment
évidemment au mouvement associatif et
puis évidemment à ce magnifique projet
ce projet structurel qui est le service
national universel qui peut-être pour
moi je sais que nous partageons cette
conviction la grande réforme de société
du quinquena d'Emmanuel Macron que
j'aurais vraiment à cœur de de faire
vivre et de construire et de construire
avec vous